PROFESSOR: Today, we continue
with our discussion of WKB.
So a few matters
regarding the WKB
were explained in the
last few segments.
We discussed there would
be useful to define
a position-dependent momentum
for a particle that's
moving in a potential.
That was a completely
classical notion,
but helped our terminology
in solving the Schrodinger
equation and set up the
stage for some definitions.
For example, a
position-dependent de Broglie
wavelength that would
be given in terms
of the position-dependent
momentum by the classic formula
that de Broglie used
for particles that move
with constant momentum.
Then in this language, the
time independent Schrodinger
equation took the
form p squared on psi
is equal to p squared
of x times psi.
This is psi of x.
And we mentioned that it was
kind of nice that the momentum
operator ended up sort of in
the style of an eigenvalue.
The eigenvalue p of x.
We then spoke about
wave functions
that in the WKB
approximation would
take a form of an exponential
with a phase and a magnitude--
so the usual notation we
have for complex numbers.
So the psi of x and p would
be written as rho of x and t
e to the i over h
bar s of x and t.
That's a typical form
of a WKB wave function
that you will see soon.
And for such wave
functions, it's
kind of manifest that rho
here is the charge density.
Because if you take the
norm squared of psi,
that gives you exactly rho.
The phase cancels.
On the other hand, the
computation of the current
was a little more interesting.
And it gave you rho times
gradient of s over m--
the mass of the particle.
So we identified the
current as perpendicular
to the surfaces of constant s or
constant phase in the exponent
of the WKB equation.
Our last comment had
to do with lambda.
And we've said that we
suspect that the semiclassical
approximation is
valid in some way
when lambda is small compared
to a physical length of a system
or when lambda changes slowly
as a function of position.
And those things we
have not quite yet
determined precisely
how they go.
And some of what
you have to do today
is understand more
concretely the nature
of the approximation.
So the semiclassical
approximation
has something to do with lambda
slowly varying and with lambda
small, in some sense.
And since you have
an h bar in here
that would make it
small if h bar is small,
we also mentioned
we would end up
considering the limit as a
sort of imaginary or fictitious
limit in which h bar goes to 0.
So it's time to try to
really do the approximation.
Let let's try to write something
and approximate the solution.
Now, we had a nice instructive
form of the wave function
there, but I will
take a simpler form
in which the wave function will
be just a pure exponential.
So setting the
approximation scheme--
so approximation-- scheme.
So before I had
the wave function
that had a norm and a phase.
Now, I want the
wave function that
looks like it just has a phase.
You would say, of course,
that's impossible.
So we will for all the time
independent Schrodinger
equation.
So we will use an s of x.
And we will write the
psi of x in the form
e to the i h bar s of x.
And you say, no,
that's not true.
My usual wave functions
are more than just phases.
They're not just faces.
We've seen wave functions
have different magnitudes.
Here that wave function will
have always density equal to 1.
But that is voided--
that criticism is voided--
if you just simply say that s
now may be a complex number.
So if s is itself a complex
number, the imaginary part of s
provides the norm of
the wave function.
So it's possible to do that.
Any rho up here can be
written as the exponential
of the log of something and then
can be brought in the exponent.
And there's no loss of
generality in writing something
like that if s is complex.
Now, we have the
Schrodinger equation.
And the Schrodinger
equation was written there.
So it's minus h squared d
second d x squared of psi of x.
It's equal to p squared of
x e to the i over h bar s.
Now, when we differentiate
an exponential,
we differentiate it two times.
We will have a couple of things.
We can differentiate the first
time-- brings an s prime down.
And the second time you can
differentiate the exponent
or you can differentiate
what is down already.
So it's two terms.
The first one would be--
imagine differentiating
the first one.
The s goes down and then the
derivative acts on the s.
So you get i over h
bar s double prime.
Let's use prime notation.
And the other one is when you
differentiate the ones here.
It brings the factor
down, again, there.
So it's plus i over h
bar s prime squared.
And then the phase
is still there,
and it can cancel between
the left and the right.
So this is equal
to p squared of x.
So I took the derivative and
cancelled the exponentials.
So cleaning this
up a little bit,
we'll have this term over here.
The h's cancel,
the sine cancels,
and you get s prime of x squared
minus i h bar s double prime.
It's equal to p squared of x.
OK.
Simple enough.
We have a derivation
of that equation.
And the first thing
that you say is,
it looks like we've
gone backwards.
We've gone from a
reasonably simple equation,
the Schrodinger
equation-- second order,
linear differential equation--
to a nonlinear equation.
Here is the function squared,
the derivative squared, second
derivative, no--
there's nothing linear
about this equation in s.
If you have one solution for
an s and another solution,
you cannot add them.
So this happens because we put
everything in the exponential.
When you take double
derivatives of an exponential
you get a term with
double derivatives
and a term with a
derivative squared.
There's nothing you can do.
And this still represents
progress in some way,
even though it has
become an equation that
looks more difficult. It can
be tracked in some other way.
So the first and
most important thing
we want to say
about this equation
is that it's a nonlinear
differential equation.
The h bar term appears in
just one position here.
And let's consider
a following claim--
I will claim that i h
bar s double prime--
this term-- is small when
v of x is slowly varying.
You see, we're having
in mind the situation
with which a particle is moving
in a potential-- a quantum
particle.
So there it s, b of
x is well-defined.
That's a term that goes
into this equation.
So this is partly known.
You may not know the energy,
but the potential you know.
And my claim-- and perhaps a
very important claim about this
equation that sets
you going clearly--
is that when v of s
is slowly varying,
this term is almost irrelevant.
That's the first thing we want
to make sure we understand.
So let's take v of x is
equal to v0 at constant.
So this is the extreme case
of a slowly varying potential.
It just doesn't vary at all.
In that case, p of x is
going to be a constant.
And that constant is the
square root of 2m e minus V0.
And what do we have here?
We have a free particle.
This v of x is a constant.
So the solution of the
Schrodinger equation,
that you know in
general, is that psi
of x is e to the
i p0 x over h bar.
That solves the
Schrodinger equation.
Now, we're talking
about this equation.
So to connect to that
equation in this situation
of constant potential
constant, momentum
in the classical sense,
and a free particle
with that constant momentum,
remember that s is a term here
in the exponential.
So for this solution here,
s of x is equal to p0 x.
That's all it is.
It's whatever is left when you
single out the i over h bar.
And let's look at that thing.
That should be a solution.
We've constructed the
solution of the momentum.
equation for constant potential.
We've read what s of x is.
That should solve this equation.
And how does it
manage to solve it?
It manages to solve it because
s prime of x is equal to p0.
s double prime of
x is equal to 0.
And the equation works out
with the first term squared--
p0 squared-- equal
to p of x squared--
which is p0 squared.
So this term, first term
in the left-hand side,
is equal to the right-hand side
This term is identically 0.
So when the potential
is constant,
that term, i h bar s double
prime, plays no role, It's 0.
So the term i h bar s
double prime is equal to 0.
So the claim now follows from
a fairly intuitive result.
If the potential is constant,
that term in the solution is 0.
If the potential
will be extremely,
slowly varying, that term
should be very small.
You cannot expect that
the constant potential has
a solution.
And you now do infinitesimal
variation of your potential,
and suddenly this
term becomes very big.
So for constant v, i h bar
is double prime equal 0.
So for slowly varying v of
x i h bar is double prime,
it should be small in the
sense that this solution
is approximately correct.
So if we do say that,
we've identified the term
in the equation that is small
when potentials are slowly
varying.
Therefore, we will
take that term
as being the small
term in that equation.
And this will be nicely
implemented by considering,
as we said, h bar going to
0, or h as a small parameter.
We will learn, as we
do the approximation,
how to quantify what something
that we call slowly varying is.
But we will take h now
as a small parameter--
that makes that term small--
and setup an expansion
to solve this equation.
That is our goal now.
So how do we set it up?
We set it up like
this-- we say s of x,
as you've learned in
perturbation theory,
is s0 of x plus h bar s1 of
x-- the first correction--
plus h bar squared is s2
of x and higher order.
Now, s already has
units of h bar--
so s0 will have
units of h bar too.
s1, for example, has no units.
So each term has a
different set of units.
And that's OK, because
h bar has units.
And this will go like
1 over h bar units
and so forth and so on.
So we have an expansion.
And this we'll call our
semiclassical expansion.
As we apply now this
expansion to that equation,
we should treat h as we treated
lambda in perturbation theory.
That is, we imagine that
this must be hauled order
by order in h bar,
because we imagine
we have the flexibility
of changing h bar.
So let's do this.
What do we have in the equation?
We have s prime.
So the equation has s0
prime plus h bar s1 prime.
Now, I will keep terms
up to order h bar.
So I will stop here-- plus
order h bar squared minus i h
bar s double prime.
So that should be s0
double prime plus order
h bar equal b squared of x.
So let's organize our terms.
We have s0 prime primed
squared on the left-hand side.
Minus p squared of x--
I bring the p to
the left-hand side--
plus h bar.
So these are terms
that have no h bar.
And when we look at the h bar
from the first term there,
we square this thing.
So you get the cross
product between the s0 prime
and the s1 prime.
So you get 2--
the h prime already is there--
s0 prime s1 prime.
And from the second
term, you get
minus i s0 double prime plus
order h squared equals 0.
So I just collected
all the terms there.
So if we're believing
in this expansion,
the first thing we should
say is that each coefficient
in the power series
of h bar is 0.
So we'll get two equations.
First one is s0 prime squared
is equal to p squared of x.
That's one.
That's this term equal to 0.
And here, we get--
let's write it in a way that
we solve for the unknown.
Supposedly from this first
equation we, can solve for s0.
If you know s0, what do you
want now to know is s1 prime.
So let's write this as
s1 prime is equal to i s0
double prime over
2 s0 zero prime.
So these are my two equations.